I
alright so let's go
Flynn was welcome here yes it's like
dead silence okay thanks for the warm
welcome guys thank you all right yeah so
how does fine with Python I notice that
this talk is labeled novice which is
kind of true because it is so easy that
the NSA can do it all right so my name
is Lynn route I am rogue Lynn on the
interwebs and this whole presentation is
at that site rogue ly / spy and I'll
show that again at the end okay so um
Who am I I am a backend engineer for
Spotify I lead pi ladies of San
Francisco and I am a board member of the
Python sulfur foundation um so I just
want to do this obligatory disclaimer
before i start i am not affiliated with
the CIA NSA FBI any other alphabet soup
groups I'm not a lawyer yes so I say
right I'm not a lawyer I'm not a black
or a white hat I'm just a Python person
and this whole presentation is just a
proof of concept there's no warranty all
right so today's talk I'll go over sort
of the historical context about what the
NSA is doing and what the NSA is doing
bringing us up to the present time and
exactly what prism is and what xkeyscore
is followed by some unanswered questions
that what they're doing leaves us and
then how exactly you can do that with
Python what this talk is not I'm not
condoning what the NSA is doing I'm not
telling you how to avoid being tracked
by the NSA i'm not encouraging you to
spy and friends family or patrons of
free Wi-Fi however that's exactly how i
did this presentation so yeah starting
off with some historical contacts tldr
too long didn't read
what the NSA is doing right now with
prism and xkeyscore is basically nothing
new so I'm starting it with a 1946 with
a group called five eyes group it's
comprised of the USA the UK australia
canada and new zealand and its purpose
this group's purpose is to share signal
intelligence each country would surveil
a set of other countries us would focus
SE on Latin America and then share that
data with Canada and well the u.s. does
not technically spy on itself there is
no stopping Canada from sharing stated
about the US citizens or like a the UK's
tempura program which pretty much does
exactly that um moving on to when the
NSA was established and sort of
originally started with US army and on
1917 after the US declared war on
Germany um it then sort of morphed into
the Armed Forces Security Agency after
World War two it couldn't really get its
[ __ ] together so Truman basically
formulated em the National Security
Agency with the FSA in 1952 all right so
only after 20 years FBI NSA was
established in over 50 years after the
start of us surveillance did the Supreme
Court require warrants for domestic
surveillance five years later after the
sentence Church Committee revealed
illegal domestic spying by the NSA in
1975 the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Act or FISA and was signed
to protect Americans a super secret
court called a foreign intelligence
surveillance court was created for the
purpose of hearing these warrants so
then 2001 911 attacks happened and a
culture sort of shifts with being more
Pro spying so within the first month
after September 11th the White House
asks the NSA
the more could be done against terrorism
if the NSA had more authority following
that the NSA resurfaces a plan saying
hey we have this plan here's how we can
do better and it's basically a training
metadata that it collected which was
originally deemed illegal in 1999 so
then you as president gives them the NSA
authority to begin the metadata
collection and targeting terrorists
Associated foreign phone numbers
continuing on and also within that first
month of right after September 11th and
the US President and cabinet sort of
scrambled to draft another ization to
spy on Americans as none had yet existed
and then so Bush signs in order to allow
the NSA's domestic spying program and
consequently now the NSA feels
authorized to spy on us calls and emails
without warrant and then the US Attorney
General was given the authorization and
told to just sign it sort of blindly
next couple years telecoms and domestic
spying sort of take place so unrevealed
telecoms and internet providers in the
u.s. received letters from the NSA
requesting data to support requesting
data and support for its domestic spying
program following that m80 employee
discovers an assay is working inside the
80's SF facility and then telecoms now
formally enter into a voluntary
agreement with the u.s. to give data to
the NSA freely without warrant then
there's the installation of a special
technology in a super secret room which
is no longer secret room 641 a at the
1880s San Francisco facility that so it
can read and analyze tens of thousands
of communications per second and then
send the communications to a central
database
then we have the total information
awareness and this program formerly
started in 2003 but the development game
began and 2000 nose aimed to gather
detailed information about individuals
to participate and prevent crimes and
the Congress stops this in late two
thousand three but the program sort of
quietly moves under the NSA's control
for the domestic spying program then in
December 2005 the New York Times reveals
that the NSA has been spying on
Americans without warrants and so soon
after bush confirms of the NSA's
warrantless eavesdropping The Times also
reveals that some of the NSA spying is
purely domestic with some telecoms
giving backdoor access to communication
streams and soon after these articles an
unknown company requests that the NSA
issue to issue court orders rather than
companies voluntarily handing over data
so previously telecoms would just give
data to the NSA into the US and now
after all this bad publicity they now
require warrants and so in 2007 and
protect America Act was passed along the
NSA now not to need warrants all right
so up till now starting in 2007 I was
prism so data collection for prism
starts with Microsoft in September in
july two thousand eight the US congress
passed amendments to the FISA act that
gives telecoms legal immunity for those
that cooperated with the NSA's
wiretapping in 2012 the NSA starts to
build its biggest spy Center in Utah for
the collection of intercepted data and
then also in 2012 the FBI pushes for
wiretap ready websites asking internet
companies to not oppose a law making
backdoors mandatory 2013 I'm sure you
remember about a year ago the Washington
Post reveals on the prison program and
shortly after that the xq
score program was revealed all right so
I got you up to what's currently going
on what exactly is the NSA doing and so
first what is prism it stands for a
planning tool for resource integration
synchronization and management it's a
bunch of words that we know but can't
really put together make sense of what
it means is it mines electronic data for
the purpose of mass surveillance it
collects intelligence that passes
through us servers and targets
foreigners but is very elusive about
data on US citizens and supposedly only
collects metadata moving on what is
xkeyscore it's a digital intelligence a
digital network intelligence
exploitation program basically a
federated query system of completely
unfiltered data as a 2008 had up to NSA
had up to 700 servers which is by far
bigger now since they have been building
the Utah data center and it gives the
ability for NSA users to query for email
addresses at targets activity phone
numbers HTTP traffic extract file
attachments etc so prism kind of
collects data xkeyscore is a database
where NSA users can basically use in
query alright so that leaves us with
some unanswered questions and what
exactly does metadata mean how do
companies not notice being backdoored or
are they lying when they're denying
cooperation how's the targets
foreignness determined how exactly are
they identifying non-us citizens and
what is done with data that's
accidentally collected on Americans and
how is the prism collected data handled
by the NSA does the NSA maintain
rigorous security measures to protect
against threats could like a hacker hack
into the NSA database and get like
everyone's information um so answering
the first question what metadata is and
why it matters
and get this actually from the FF
presentation last year they know that
you rang a sex phone service at 224 am
spoke for 18 minutes but they don't know
what you talked about they know that you
called a suicide prevention hotline from
the Golden Gate Bridge but the topic
remains secret and they know that you
spoke within the HIV testing service
then your doctor then your insurance
company within the same hour they don't
know what's discussed so this is a
really good kind of display of what
metadata is and you can kind of connect
dots about even though the content of an
email or discussion is not saved it's it
still can be presumed now how exactly is
the NSA doing it and this is sort of
presumably and so it's through a tier 1
the backbone of the internet and tier 1
Internet allows that vast amounts of
data to flow through one endpoint to
another via the simplest path versus
consumer internet which just looks for
the cheapest path in major companies
like Facebook Google Microsoft are able
to tap into these tier 1 networks
through entry points called edges and
then so rather than walking on to like
Google or Facebook status enters and be
noticed the NSA's sort of wiretaps these
edges between major companies and the
tier 1 network it's probably more like
this you know there's an XKCD comic for
everything if you can't see it it's in
the crypto nerds imagination his laptop
is encrypted let's build a
million-dollar cluster to crack it it's
no good plus our evil plan is foiled and
what actually happens is you know let's
drug him and beat him with a five-dollar
wrench to get the password right so the
NSA has a lot of muscle and probably
easier than actually like cracking like
um like 4096 bit RSA keys all right so
getting to how you can do it how you can
do this with Python real quick the tools
that I'm using
um basically this presentation and all
the tools i did was in ipython and i'm
using scape e which is kind of like TCP
dump in in Python which is just packet
sniffing and manipulation I'm using pi
geoip which is an API for geoip
databases geo JSON bindings and
utilities for a Geo Jason and then a
Python mrn map which is a wrapper around
Python a wrapper around and Matt port
scanner and so if you want to play along
this presentation again is that rogue
doubt lee / spy and if you just remember
this presentation you can get the links
to everything else including this
notebook quick introduction to escape
you that i'm about to give all the
queries in all the repose of these
notebooks alright so to get everyone up
to speed since I'm using Skippy and it's
my latest crush for Python so this makes
me cringe the import star but that's how
they documented and then so here I'm
sniffing lie on traffic I'm limiting to
my interface of on and 0 which is my
default like Wi-Fi I'm filtering for TCP
traffic in port 80 and only grabbing 10
TCP packets um you can see that after 10
packets oh I I have a sniff object and
then if I see the dot res you get kind
of like a barf of data kind of doesn't
really make sense just to grab the first
packet of the 10 you can see a lot less
data but still still a bar from data
escaping has this dot show function so
you can actually see the packet and
rendered more pretty I guess so you have
the ethernet layer the IP layer and the
TCP layer and some familiar things like
protocol TTL some flags etc alright so
that's essentially how i'm using scape
ii and that's pretty much all i need to
know in order to like spy on Pete
so the following queries are examples of
them xkeyscore queries um these the
essay has a presentation that it gave to
its users or its employees that was made
public they had a really bad design on
their slides so this is pretty much the
same kind of thing but prettier slides
and Python and again these are just
proof of concept and that's I'm not
storing any data and I'm not condoning
spying on friends family or anywhere
where there's free Wi-Fi however that's
exactly what I did alright so the first
query the first xkeyscore query I'm show
me everyone that has searched for a
certain term so I'm setting up escapee I
have already saved a cat file and I can
sniff via online or offline or I can the
online sniffing this is my filter using
TCP and host vs search yahoo com I'm
limiting 2 30 or three hundred packets
now the reason i'm choosing searched
yahoo com at the time was traffic wasn't
over HTTPS it was still over HTTP
whereas google and put it over https i
think yahoo has since changed them um so
we have some 300 TCP packets and you can
do a dot n summary and get sort of a
nice view of all packets you can see
again the ethernet/ip TCP layer from ipd
to IP over what protocol and the like
Stan and act flags now I'm just going to
grab a certain packet and here again you
can see the layers and we have a fourth
layer bra and I want to drill into this
raw layer so I'm using get layer it kind
of looks um some text looks interesting
like the egg
yes so I'm doing a little parsing and I
can get my first search query which was
Madrid I know when I was playing with
Yahoo that and it's like on the URL it's
what it's queries via thank thee ? p
equals and I'm just grabbing the load
part of that and saw my second query in
a different packet i can see that i
searched for I love chocolate because
i'm not creative with my search queries
and then the last one you can see that i
was searching for our blue bottle coffee
so it's quite easy so long as you can
set up escapee to sniff traffic on a
certain host that you can grab all the
packets and sort of iterate through them
looking for a particular like URL I
guess query parameters and so you can
easily see that I search for certain
things alright so the next query show me
everyone from a certain country that has
visited a certain extremist form so
again from skippy import star i have a
sample HTTP cap file and i have about 41
TCP packets and to you too p packets
just grabbing one again ethernet IP tcp
and some load data now I'm just grabbing
the load i can see that basically HTTP
headers that we're all familiar with and
then but i can just see if a certain
someone visited a host or an extreme is
for form now trying to figure out where
this person is i did a simple hacky a
traceroute function based on scabies
trace route and i got a bunch of IP
addresses using a chi GOI pity you can
kind of plot that against geoip database
and i'm getting coordinates i have all
these sort of coordinates of where those
IP addresses
making a Geo JSON file out of that with
Python I can you can see it looks like a
dictionary but when you save it to a
file it's a Geo JSON format and then I
actually just uploaded it to github
because github gists easily vendor geo
JSON in an awesome map so you can see
the sort of traffic that I did when
visiting a host I think I start was in
the Sweden at the time and you can see
it goes I think through Switzerland and
then to the US in the UK so even even if
the host was like in the UK and I'm in
Sweden you can see the path that it
takes is through the US so ensa sort of
has jurisdiction over sniffing those
packets all right xquery give me all
emails with a certain text in the body
of an email I have a sample smtp packet
or pcap file and here's the summary and
you can kind of see some familiar things
like a Dana's queria the mail address
and some smtp traffic in again d flags
grabbing just packet number 12 I guess
in this case and getting the raw layer I
see this raw load now I'm kind of just
splitting it up to make it easily more
readable it looks kind of encoded right
so i'm going to i was just try to base64
decode and i could see that it was an
email address the following packet let's
see if we can decode that string again
and it turns out it's a password prompt
and then the next packet after that
another encoded string what could this
be it's the the dudes password so mind
you I got this like sample smtp pcap
file off of like Wireshark online so
this dude who upload the pcap file new
completely what he was doing
so I this is probably just a dummy
password I'm hoping that he's since
changed it so if I wanted to sort of see
what's in the body of the email i made a
quick and dirty like filter packet
filtering function and i wanted to see
if the word attachment was in that email
so here i had this little query found
and this is basically the whole email
you can see the from and the two of the
subject these again these is this is
like metadata and then going down it
says find the attachment so here's a
word I was looking for and actually you
can see the plaintext attachment of what
was sent alright so that is that third
query now moving on to the fourth query
and give me PGP usage from a certain
country so i have a sample a pgp email
that i did for fun i'm just reading and
now you can see that all the email
hitters headers are in plain text and
then the actual body of the email is
encoded with them gpg so if i just
wanted to see if it was encoded i can
just search for this string which is a
header in email and protocol is
application pgp encrypted and then
here's my quick and dirty email parser /
a traceroute function and it's basically
like my other traceroute function i'm
just getting the IP addresses i'm making
a Geo json again like before and here i
can see the route i believe if i
remember this correctly this I was
actually doing in Sweden emailing my
friend in Germany so you can see the
path it takes to get from Sweden to
Germany or maybe it was from Germany to
Sweden and again it's going through the
US servers in a bunch of other countries
alright so fifth query show me chaps for
a certain user during a certain time
frame I have another cat file that I've
I have offline and i can see that i have
over a thousand TCP packets over a
thousand UDP packets and some others um
and showing this i can see that i have
you know dns query of some free node
which is familiar for IRC um and if we
go on I'm just doing kind of a pretty
printing of the file itself you can sort
of see chats going on let's see private
message going on from someone to someone
else now if we just sort of look for
this is a quick and dirty filter
function if we just look for the user
amarak you can easily see like the
conversation that's going on from amarak
private message how um how do you mean a
what-what can see that a real
conversation going on and i guess just
side note only connect to IRC over ssl
because obviously this is not over ssl
alright this is the final query find all
exploitable machines in z country now
i'm going to tell you how to find them
i'm not going to tell you how to exploit
them you can search that on your own
anyways i'm using the Python wrapper for
nmap and i'm scanning bitbucket / ports
22 through 443 and this is the output
and the wrapper it gives you a nice like
value that you can copy it's just the
command line if you want to run it in
your terminal and then you can see that
use TCP and it's can these addresses and
this is the hostname and then you could
see over TCP it was a port 25 was is the
smtp port port 53 was is a DNS port
where
mind is on with that version port 80 we
have engine decks with one point five
point three poor 110 is pop and then so
on and so um if you like knew that a
certain version of bind or engine X that
certain version was exploitable you can
go ahead and have your fun with that so
now I'm just grabbing the IP address of
the bit bucket hosts that I scan and
then plotting it making it a Geo JSON
here's the file again and you can't
really see that quite yet but um it's in
the middle of Denver or Colorado
somewhere so you can easily see you can
easily scan hosts and then take the IP
addresses and kind of find out where
they are mind you that as soon as i did
a port scan on bitbucket and i try to do
it again and they completely blocked me
so that so that they can companies can
be aware of if they're being port scan
alright so wrapping up I went over the
long store compressa dense of a mass
surveillance with them very little
oversight or restriction in the US and
the cooperation abroad and safe to
assume that the NSA is spying on
literally everyone I gave you a
conjecture of how the NSA is actively
backdooring communications and how to
effectively get yourself on the no-fly
list not really hopefully not I don't
know and then how to implement your own
toy prism and xkeyscore in Python so any
other information that you want if you
missed something you can find it at
roble dot spy thank you
it's like five minutes for questions or
something exactly I'm sure there are
comments questions maybe not everyone's
scared did I scare everyone it's time to
take out your tin foil hat and go
underground if you I mean if you're too
shy I'll be down at the sprints for your
Python so we can chat too okay you guys
are too nice you don't want to grill me
alright thanks folks really no one yeah
okay thanks again
you